what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to my
new favorite youtuber like i actually
genuinely am a big fan of him his
the better bachelor um response video to
that started at the bottom and worked
her way down before i start do not
forget to like comment
and subscribe also let me know i'm like
is it youtube ethical to react
to reaction videos i don't really know
but
if there's an issue let me know in the
comments but i really enjoy like
where it feels like i'm having a
conversation with him
so like i have her thoughts his thoughts
and i can add my thoughts but
i could see why people may
see it differently but just let me know
okay
guys welcome to better bachelor this is
joker with a face for radio and a voice
for print today
um this is a video that somebody emailed
me and one of my viewers here and they
said hey go check this out
here's a girl that um you know did some
bad stuff
and uh she uh i don't know
i don't want to read his email exactly
because he didn't give me permission too
but it was basically like hey look at
this
hypocritical typical girl doing bad
stuff
check it out see what you think of it
and i watched the whole video and
what's interesting is that uh i actually
feel
a little sorry for her why not because
of her choices
she learned her lessons from her choices
but she ended up
winding up the bad boy that she ended up
getting was a raging narcissist
and might have even been a little bit
dangerous but that's that's not here nor
there
that's not part of the lesson today that
the part of the takeaway today
is what happens when you let those
emotions for the bad boy
override your logic and your sense and
you go for the bad boy instead of the
nice guy it also talks a little we're
going to talk a little bit about how
bringing baggage forward from
relationship to a relationship without
ever
taking time to heal and get over your
issues before continuing on
can lead to many many problems in your
life so
let's get started here and uh and then
we'll kind of i had to break it up into
lots of chunks
because again if i if i let it run on
for too long
i can get hit with a copyright stuff
it's a 45 minute video i cut it down to
15.
a lot of what she says is i learned from
this there's self-reflection
i messed up here's how you can avoid
this so i've only picked out
kind of the bad from the video so keep
that in mind as you watch this
that she it's interesting how he talks
about
like bringing baggage from previous
relationships into this relation
into like new relationships because
i i've seen like personally how that
affects like
friends of mine and just like even me at
times
actually learned a pretty valuable
lesson and um
maybe she'll take that moving forward so
let's let's get into it and then we'll
discuss it as we go
um the marriage i was in and i say i was
in
because um we are separated again
um but this time i did file for a
divorce
notice she said separate it again so it
went bad right off the beginning
and they're already divorced but she
filed
so she will statistically go down as one
of the 60
of women that file for divorce not him
so i just thought i'd put a pause there
and make that mention that
she filed just like we mentioned
happened so many times
because i want you guys to know that i
take full radical responsibility for my
end
and i never want this to be something
where i'm like pointing the finger
outward and just
playing victim because that's not what
i'm here to do i put then that in that
in there to be nice to her
to let you this is she does 40 more
minutes or i should say 30 more minutes
of that
that she does talk understanding the
choices that she made because hindsight
is always 20 20. it's easy afterwards to
look back and say
man i shoulda i could i would have red
flags warnings
which is why we do these videos to show
you some of the red flags
to show you some of the warnings
beforehand she sees them now
but the takeaways i want you to hear the
way she talks about this guy
when she even now when she talks about
this guy
and what he did to her emotions and
how irrational she went when she was
thinking about him
hindsight is such a [ __ ] like you
especially as a girl with girls when you
realize how
emotionally you make decisions hindsight
is always
always always always 20 20.
i'm 32 years old you know i'm
i was finding myself just like in this
marriage that
was going down
a road and i had seen
major major red flags way before i even
said
i do now the interesting thing is she i
had to cut some of this out again but
she saw her own red flags but later on
she realized you know what i had some
trauma i have to get over i had some
problems too
and she brought that into the
relationship obviously he brought some
things fell apart but again it did not
dissuade her
from chasing after him
and corey was right i mean he told me he
looked me in the face and said lynette
you
love the idea of me um
you love the idea of marriage
and now in hindsight
i really think he was right well i
i think a lot of women have that
biological clock that's like
ticking in their head and i think that
hollywood's really sold us on the fact
that we have one person
that is our soul mate that's gonna love
us no matter what when and
actuality you get to pick like it's not
like
that's your person you get to pick and
the choices that you make
determine like who wants you and who you
get to pick
yep they love the idea of marriage the
big wedding this the partner to to
go through thick and thin with i have
somebody by my side yeah but if you
don't again if you're not being honest
with your history and they're not honest
with theirs
and you're bringing forth baggage it's
not gonna work out for
for either party
corey waltz into my life and he actually
was coming to me
for advice about his ex who was leaving
him for a woman
and that's how our conversation really
kind of got started
um he had a dog i had a dog we went to
the dog park and
and then lo and behold like there was
chemistry there which
i will say one thing i will not deny
like corey and i have incredible
chemistry
so how many times have we heard honey
don't worry now maybe
she doesn't say she was dating somebody
at the time but what if you're in a
relationship
she says look he's got a girlfriend
they're breaking up or they're having a
fight we're just talking
or you know he's just a friend we're
just going to the dog park because he
has a dog i have a dog
we're just hanging out he's just a
friend
but there's chemistry this is why you
have to be careful with
friends and it's not just new friends
things can happen
between old friends as well just
sometimes times change
situations change feelings change so
always be
cautious very cautious if a woman has
a lot of guy friends what do you guys
determine
as a lot of guy friends like one two
five
i don't have that many friends like in
general so
and that's all lovely to have chemistry
uh
but also there needs to be so much more
than that
and so our relationship from the get-go
was always rocky i mean we never were in
a committed relationship
so hindsight's 20 20 but she he never
committed to her
it was always rocky so why why would she
even get into a relationship with
somebody like that
because they're the bad boy because but
that's
so i i understand a lot of girls take it
really really
personally when god like the guy that
they want like doesn't want them because
they don't realize that they're
competing with 80
of women like if you realized that
i think you'd probably take it a lot
less personally because they're
mysterious they're
aloof he'd never committed to her you'll
see
i went straight from the arms of my
ex-girlfriend like a month later
um into this whirlwind with cory and we
weren't official like we just were
dating casually
so that's kind of interesting she had an
ex-girlfriend and she went straight from
one relationship to another one
that is it's not healthy you haven't had
time to heal over the past relationship
nor are you prepared to get into the
next one but again she's chasing the
feelings she's chasing maybe not wanting
to be alone
maybe he's very exciting and as a woman
your clock is ticking you only have so
much time to have kids
so i think that's why a lot of women
bounce from like relationship to
relationship to really interesting
the tingles are there so she chases
after it but you notice he never
committed to her he never committed to
her
wound up in this like saga with cory's
this was like seven eight years ago and
from the beginning he said you know i'm
focused on business i'm not looking for
a relationship and he was very clear
um but i just was
absolutely enamored by him and so it
just became this like
thing yeah see he and i've told you guys
this too
always tell the truth number one and
number two always trade chase your
dreams do not change
or alter your course for her
well that's what this guy did he said
i'm not looking for a relationship
and he was being honest about it and he
said he was chasing his dreams and doing
his things
and that he was honest about it but it
didn't dissuade her it didn't make her
less attracted to him
it made her more attracted to him she
wanted to date him even more
and so she did even though she knows
even now she the way she's talking now
she could see the problems she could see
he wasn't into her in the same way
it didn't stop her yeah but um i don't
think it's like i wonder why that is
like and i think the older women get the
wiser they
go about making these different
decisions but it's tough because they
have less to bargain with
so to speak there was no commitment
there so
the foundation that was built was very
rocky because
we were intimate and not in any sort of
like there was no
safety there for my heart see and this
is why i tell
girl like i don't want to get into like
what's happened to me or like what
whatever but
this is why i tell girls that like
the longer you can stay a virgin like
literally
that's the that's a very attractive like
thing to a guy do not just give that
to anyone and the more
in the longer you can wait to have sex
with someone the more you'll really see
their true intentions
see the guy was basically
and and again i'm leaping here because
she doesn't say a lot of this but
it sounds like at least to me that he
was enjoying the physicality of it but
he was not
in a place where he could emotionally
give to her
but it doesn't matter to her it didn't
matter because she
was emotionally into him and the more
they exchanged the physical
stuff the more she started getting
feelings but he
did not because women attach
through through sex and men don't
mention through like quality time and so
he didn't reciprocate it
he he just kept on going but it didn't
stop her from falling in love
and this is where i think you know we
talk about and i did an episode on this
a
a couple of weeks ago a woman would
rather share
a great guy than to have a
what she feels is an average guy all to
herself
now again it's all perception so the guy
that she may think is a great guy may
not be a great guy right but a woman
if she thinks he's a great guy she'd
rather share him than have a he's
average guy
all to herself you'll hear what that
comes up
there's been this like a little
feeling you know of insecurity from the
get-go of our relationship and we dated
off and on like that for four years
damn that is such a long time
and what that's such a bad foundation to
starts
and i think she knows that now but
that's such a bad oh my god i just
almost hit my eye
bad foundation to start any relationship
on like because that's disrespectful
without him calling my girlfriend
calling me his girlfriend
um and i was like pining over him
like i'm not kidding i just
became so enthralled
by him um i was like in his vortex
see again he kept his frame he didn't
he didn't give her anything except you
know maybe some dates
and maybe a little bit of fun time but
because she saw him as such a high level
guy
of with all these qualities and that
that he's chasing his dreams and he's
this and he's that
that she was just enamored by him and
because as a woman
there's like maybe three to five
qualities that girls look for like it's
probably like
height um ambition um
you know maybe politics really like
whatever
four or five things i would guess that
every girl
like looks for and when a girl like
finds a guy that she feels like has the
qualities that she's looking for
she places him on a pedestal and just
thinks
that he can do no wrong and
when a lot of times it's really not the
highest quality of partner
and he gave nothing in return or very
little at this point the way she's
talking
he and it's surprising that so many guys
think you know
i did this for her i was nice to her i
was kind to her i
doesn't matter doesn't matter if she
sees you as a high enough
or a high enough value or that you are
um unobtainable doesn't matter she's
she's gonna fall
whether she wants to or not
i was so in love with him that
like i really started losing all sense
of like who i was and
what really lit me up inside again
she's so in love with him he wouldn't
even call her
his girlfriend and it's a little more
telling because come to find out he was
dating other women and you know what
she knew it and you know what else she
was okay with it
she probably wasn't okay with it she
just accepted it
is that i mean because she didn't want
to lose we're dating and from the
beginning
i mean like i said he would like date
other people and come back like we were
totally sleeping together and then he
would come back
from like some trip that he met somebody
else and he would be like
i'm dating this person too and then the
value she feels about herself just goes
lower and lower and lower
because in her head she keeps thinking
like i'm not even worth
this guy calling
me his girlfriend when she really she's
just entangled with the wrong guy i want
to explore it so
are you cool like he didn't even ask are
you cool that like it was just like this
is the case so
sounds pretty alpha doesn't it sounds
pretty like the man just
this is the way it is if you're not cool
with it you can bounce this is what's
happening now
that was his frame now turns out he's a
raging narcissist
but the reason why i have a little
compassion for her is i dated a
narcissist now
when they stepped out on me things were
very different i didn't continue to date
and all that part of it
but i i can see what happens because
narcissists have this weird
they can gaslight and they have this
weird personality about them that is
very
uh very attractive and um i learned my
lesson very quickly but
she did not and here she already should
have had the warning bells especially
when he's giving her
he's giving her physicality and
virtually nothing else
and then he steps out with other women
and he's like if you don't like this
it's just the way it is but again she'll
share a winner
rather than have a a regular guy i
almost said loser but that's not fair
it's not even a loser it's just an
average guy all to herself
you can see how she's chasing
relationally i was a mess and i just
didn't know what to think about who he
was or how we were going to end up and
like i said pining over him so i was
trying to date other people too but i
just like really wanted to be with him
and it was this saga that continued and
that was from the very beginning
and the thing about girls like this is
they'll so she ended up getting the ring
i'm actually interested to see how that
it clearly didn't work out for her and
she ended up leaving him
but it's interesting because i remember
like
seeing girls be in that like
in between zone and then wait it out and
end up getting the relationship
and getting what they wanted and
it's interesting to like
like i'm curious to see like how that
ended up happening but
i'm sure like she had seen people that
had done the same thing and it ended up
on the outside looking in good for them
even though
you know anyone that saw the
relationship from the inside
knows that i'm sure there was issues
she's going to tell us
now imagine you're a guy that goes out
on a date with a woman like this
and you have a couple of good dates
maybe you even have some fun in the
bedroom
but then she just kind of ghosts you or
then she doesn't
contact her she seems to drift away and
you look at yourself and you say
what am i what did i do wrong i thought
things were going well
might not have anything to do with you
yes this is such good advice for guys
because when a girl is hung up on a guy
like that like
she's not good to the other guys
interested so do not
take it personally and let me know guys
do you feel like it's the same thing for
women like if a guy's hung up on a girl
that is kind of like using him or
playing him do you feel like he is bad
then
to other girls that are interested in
him you could be a great guy
but she she's out there dating while
she's basically in love with this guy
but he won't give her the time of day so
she's like
let me move on but she couldn't move on
because her heart was involved so she
might have dated gone out on some
average fun dates
but her heart and this is why i say you
shouldn't date when you're not
when you're not in a good place today
she wasn't in a good place today
yeah so she really wasn't giving these
other guys a fair chance
and these other guys probably didn't do
anything wrong and the thing is if
you're a girl in that situation
if you don't think you have the
willpower to like cut them off
literally move and i say this in like
the kindest way possible
if you don't think that when they're
close by like
you have the willpower to like say no
get put get out of that situation
do not put yourself in a situation where
you could waste
years of your life especially like your
good years
on a guy that doesn't deserve you after
it was still
still not official we were never
official he was kind of seeing people
down in long beach i was seeing people
in la
um i got to date some
wildly incredible people but i didn't
let anyone in
she met she she she was in love with
alpha
chad and uh beta guys came in to get
some dates
and she tried but it wasn't enough to
tear her heart away from
from the guy that would not give her the
time of day wouldn't call her the
girlfriend wouldn't make it official
because again his status now i don't
know he may be
tall and incredibly good looking and
successful and athletic and
all the other things out there but you
notice he gave
nothing but she still couldn't help it
and even dating other
women she still couldn't leave him alone
again
logically you look and you say but that
doesn't make any sense why would she
want a guy that would love her
and care for her and be there for her
and it doesn't matter
the butterflies do what the butterflies
do so if you've been out
with uh and something happened bad on a
date a lot of times don't let it reflect
poorly on you don't let you don't look
at yourself in the mirror and say what
did i do wrong
maybe it was something that was never in
your control at all
i literally had this wall up because
i was so in love with cory
that i didn't even allow myself
to explore even the idea of being with
anyone else
so i was dating other people but like
really barreling through their hearts
which is really unfair
like there was one relationship that was
really unfair now she does go on for
probably another five minutes and i had
to cut this out because again like
i said it gets so long but she did go
through and she said
i think i left that part in here i don't
know if i did or not but she said i'm
sorry i was a bad person
like i ran up a lot of guys into the
ground i wasn't fair about it
i look back upon that if you're watching
this i'm sorry so again
she does have some self-reflection here
i just cut most of it out for time
and that's what hindsight is always 20
20. i swear
so um to all of you if any of you end up
landing on here
that i have hurt in the process um you
know who you are and i'm
very sorry um
and if i could take it back and redo
some different things you know
i would just be more communicative i
wouldn't change anything necessarily but
i would communicate better
like i said hindsight's 2020 but but
what
she she at least she's learning it now
but what would have helped as if she had
learned it beforehand
is the same thing i've said three times
now don't move forward
until you're over your past if you're
looking in the rearview mirror
you're going to run into a wall you got
to clear the
get the back baggage out of the way
before you sail forward
now a lot of you guys you know we talk
here about like myself i don't really
date now
some of you still want to date some of
you are married but the the takeaway is
when so many times guys say you know
something
i've been burned i've been hurt
i was treated poorly this is
you know and she didn't go into it
thinking she was gonna hurt somebody
she didn't go into it it's a very sunny
day i gotta keep it and that's why i
always say a lot of this stuff is very
unconscious to women like i don't even
think women
realize that they do it because as i've
been like watching the manosphere like
videos there's stuff that people have
said
and i'm like oh like i used to do that
and i didn't even realize why i was
doing it and that's why this
conversation is really
like interesting to me because
you start to realize like the reasons
you're doing things
and yeah i don't know adjusting my
aperture here um
she didn't go into it trying to be a bad
person but she was even if it was by
accident
and the guys on this receiving end maybe
they're here now saying
i swore off women man i can't deal with
this anymore
uh it's but at least she admits she did
it but you gotta let go your past before
you move on
i finally threw up my hands and i was
like you know what i'm gonna let the
nice guy have a chance
so i met this guy at church and um
he was lovely absolutely lovely and
we're still in communication he's
amazing
um not like that it's like totally
friendly but he
uh really wanted to pursue me and so we
started dating but this weird thing was
still happening with cory and so he kind
of like went up to him at church and was
like
bro i'm just gonna be really honest with
you like i want to pursue this woman
she's amazing
but you either need to marry her or like
get in back the line
beta bucks alpha
keeps dating the girl see she said
that's it i'm just gonna give this guy a
chance i'm gonna we're gonna go for it
so i met this guy in church and yet
somehow
he knew about corey and he went up to
corey
i guess that's the guy's name if i'm
getting it right and he told corey you
either need to marry or step
off why did he even know about corey
because she was still talking about
corey could she still love
cory how did he know who corey was
because i'm sure he saw some pictures
or i'm sure she was still hanging out
with him obviously
so captain beta here was like you need
to
do the right thing or step off but but
the guy the guy should have just walked
away and that probably would have been
more attractive to her than what he
ended up doing
like he's like fighting her battles for
her that he shouldn't even have to deal
with he should have just walked away
and then she would have had to like
think about what she was losing
and alpha dude's like come on babe like
she never she says she gave these other
guys a chance
she never gave anyone else a chance what
do you guys think a girl should do
like mentally if she is so attracted to
the one guy
but she like wants like how do you it's
interesting because they give like
advice to men but i'd be really
interested to say like
what he would give to women because i
could definitely see her perspective
like
um being in a situation where you're
like
super attracted to like the guy you
shouldn't want and i hear girls talk
about this all the time
so i'll just be interested to see what
he says
that's how much of a draw he had on her
because again he's living his best life
and he's doing what's right for him
and she couldn't get over it and he gave
her nothing
still to this point he's given her
nothing
because he was like she's so obsessed
with you like i can't even get in
to try and like you know
date her because she's so focused on you
yeah see if you get to the point where
she goes uh my ex-boyfriend and my
ex-boyfriend and my ex be
your bail she's not over it yet she's
not over it
or um oh yeah i'm still friends with my
ex bail
she's not over it and and if she is then
why i mean either why did you break up
if he broke up with her he shouldn't be
in her life anymore
if she broke up with him it was for a
wee reason and
what's the point of keeping him around
anymore and and you know something if i
if an x came to me
that i was still friends with and said
you know some i'm going to pursue this
relationship with this guy
and i want to give it a real good shot i
don't think it's fair that we're friends
anymore
my answer to that would be i hear that
give it all you got man do it
that's the right answer but if if if
captain
you know save a hoe here is all still up
in her life and she can't let him go
this other guy had didn't even have a
chance
he could have won the situation by just
saying you know what you're still into
this other good
dude i gotta go but nope he just tried
to hang in there and hang in there and
make something happen
wasn't gonna happen um
yeah that's exactly what i said so it
wasn't long after that that he kind of
like all of a sudden
snapped out of it and was like i wanna
do this
full-on let's do this i got no reasons
for that
why why this dude decided to do that
i don't know i don't know but um
but he did do you think because he saw
competitors that was why he decided to
do it
and then like six months later we were
engaged and see that's a mistake on both
her part this other
she shouldn't have why she thinks this
guy that was dating other women at the
same time as her
is in a place to marry i don't know and
why that guy
proposed and did all this i got nothing
um
i got i got nothing on that big mistake
by both of them
i've never seen that happen so let me
know in the comments
why you think that happened and we had
no money
but i was like finally
he sees me how i want him to see me all
i wanted was for him to see me as like
wife material or something because i had
so much
insecurity from the past spoiler alert
he didn't see her as wife material
and you notice she has so many
insecurities from the past that baggage
came forward
he brought his problems forward they put
it in a big pot
and got married obviously it didn't work
out
but you know and again the blame goes
just as much on this
on this dummy as her if he just kept
living his good life and just
kept dating and doing his thing him
proposing was a massive massive mistake
because for her she thinks it makes her
happy
but it doesn't she thinks she's changing
him but it doesn't she thinks this
wins the man but it doesn't
no that's that's so true and again like
i said it's coming from such early
childhood stuff so i encourage
all of you guys to do the work inside
that only you can do
before you even try and like loop people
into your mess and your
you know your situation like do the
inner work
and that's my best advice to any of you
that are going down a journey of wanting
to invite conscious partnership into
your life
she's very earth crunchy and crystal
healing and all this other stuff but
but i left this in there again to show
that she has reflected on this and has
learned a lesson
but it's a great video because this lets
me
tell you guys using her as an example is
this is some of the women that you meet
out there
this is the girl that broke up with you
this is the girl that left for no reason
this is the girl that seems to still
love her ex-boyfriend even though he's a
jerk
that here she is and again it's not the
new guy's fault
it's the fact that she can't get over
her past before moving on
and this is why i tell girls
to really really be cautious
because like what seems like a small
decision
to like hook up with someone or do
something with someone
could have repercussions for years down
the line you have no idea so before you
give yourself up to someone make sure
you
really really know that person
especially if you're young like
you have no idea the damage like you can
do to yourself like
years down the line and then the amount
of work it takes to like undo all of it
just avoid it i've been
i've dated very powerful people that had
like could have completely taken care
of me and i could have had a very
different story but
my mindset was always like i want to
build with my partner you know i don't
want to marry into money
um i tried that whole thing and i mean
like i
dated people that were really powerful
in hollywood and i just was like
ugh like see money and status
well the money part maybe they had
status too
but this other guy that she's head over
heels with maybe he had
now she said they had no money when they
got married but maybe he had status
and maybe he had that attitude and good
charisma
and again you know i've i've dated
people that have this
they're very hard to walk away from
because they're very good at gaslighting
you and
messing with your emotions to where it
can really make you really mess with
your head
it's a spoiler alert he didn't see her
as wife material
and you notice she has so many
insecurities from the past that baggage
came forward
he brought his problems forward they put
it in a big pot
and got married obviously it didn't work
out
but you know i and again the blame goes
just as much on this
on this dummy as her if he just kept
living his good life
and just kept dating and doing his thing
him proposing was a massive massive
mistake because
for her she thinks it makes her happy
but it doesn't she thinks she's changing
him
but it doesn't she thinks this wins the
man
but it doesn't and again like i said
it's coming from such early childhood
stuff so i encourage
all of you guys to do the work inside
that only you can do
before you even try and like loop people
into your mess and your
you know your situation like do the
inner work
and that's my best advice to any of you
that are going down a journey of wanting
to invite conscious partnership into
your life
she's very earth crunchy and crystal
healing and all this other stuff but but
i left this in there again to show that
she has reflected on this and has
learned a lesson
but it's a great video because this lets
me
tell you guys using her as an example is
this is some of the women that you meet
out there
this is the girl that broke up with you
this is the girl that left for no reason
this is the girl that seems to still
love her ex-boyfriend even though he's a
jerk
that here she is and again it's not
the new guy's fault it's the fact that
she can't get over
her past before moving on
i've been i've dated very powerful
people that had like
could have completely taken care of me
and i could have had a very different
story but
my mindset was always like i want to
build with my partner you know i don't
want to marry into money
um i tried that whole thing and i mean
like i
dated people that were really powerful
in hollywood and i just was like oh like
see money and status well the money part
maybe they had status too but this other
guy that she's head over heels with
maybe he had no she said they had no
money when they got married but maybe he
had status
and maybe he had that attitude and good
charisma
and again you know this is so true
a guy could win the lottery and it'll
increase his chances at like gold
diggers but i swear
when i say ambition i do not mean money
because if a girl sees that like a guy
like works hard
and like is you know easy to talk to
whatever that's worth more than money at
least like to me
and from what i've seen i've i've dated
people that have this
they're very hard to walk away from
because they're very good at gaslighting
you
and messing with your emotions to where
it can really
really mess with your head that's what
this guy did to her now it doesn't give
her any excuses but she didn't know what
she was looking out for
and she kept trying to move ahead before
clearing out her past
and and she's thinking marriage is gonna
fix this or
change this or she's gonna change him to
be wined and dine in romance is not a
bad thing ladies like to be taken care
of is not a bad
thing and i literally wouldn't let
myself receive
um so that's something that i've majorly
been looking at and trying to heal
yeah she's 32 now divorced
and the guys she's gonna be encountering
or not the
tall dark handsome rich popular blah
blah blah
it's gonna be average guys maybe with
good jobs maybe with good careers
but that she's pretty she'll still have
a good amount of guys that want to date
her
i'm sure like not the same options that
she had like 10 years ago
of course duh but i i i bet you she gets
remarried that's when the
the the attention that you might have
gotten at one point in time when you're
24
now that you're at 32 things are
changing and it's time to settle down
maybe find a stable smart successful guy
to have a family with
that can help with the kids well
miraculously now
she's kind of understanding it's okay to
receive gifts
it's okay maybe enjoy a little bit of
that finer things in life
shocking i did kind of give him an
ultimatum and
he made his decision and then as every
saga goes like i did i ended up
starting to really resent him because i
felt like he wasn't pulling
his weight she says to him marry me or
get out it's over and he says okay let's
get married
and then surprisingly he didn't change
he didn't pull his weight
he didn't seem interested no surprises
here
mary find the bad boy chase the bad boy
catch the bad boy change the bad boy
dump the bad boy on a high i was
so busy and i was so stressed out that i
was taking a lot of my stressors out on
him
and that included both verbal i mean i
let loose on him um and made him feel
very inadequate which i am not proud of
whatsoever um
and also that include i mean our fights
were so terrible you guys
i thought we were going to end up on 20
20. so
verbal come to find out later physical
she gave just as good as she got so it's
it's a two-way street
so oftentimes when we hear that the guy
did this or the guy did that
it's not always just the guy's fault
sometimes the woman can initiate it
that's ah that sounds so bad it's true
though
it's true like some girls drive men to
go nuts
it was so toxic and it was toxic even
before we got married so that's what i
mean when i said earlier about
having like major red flags because i
kind of knew
i kind of knew like there was like
definitely
tendencies to go violent directions
before the wedding
but i was so embarrassed and i didn't
want to call off the wedding because
i remember one moment before the wedding
that it got bad
and he was like i'm going to call your
dad and call this off and da da i
remember in my head going
this shouldn't happen i should not be
getting married
the butterflies and the feelings and the
the the desire for this guy to be able
to ha
he he he had multiple women he's a great
guy he's such a catch
he's so hot he doesn't give me any
affirmation but now if
if i can rope him in i get this amazing
guy
all to myself except he's not so amazing
yeah but again that logic the the
slowing down and looking at things from
an outside view
was affected by number one his his hold
on her and number two
all the bad paths she had that she
hadn't let go but girls like this are
addicted to the chase like they want to
chase the guy
and as when the chase goes away that's
that's when she gets divorced like your
gut
knows trust that um
because i look back now and go man and
again i don't want to like change or
wish anything away it's just more that i
look i'm learning from this
hindsight's 20 20. we spent thousands in
cup before we found our other coaches
that i just recommended we spent
thousands in therapy and couples like
we tried everything or i should say i
tried because it was typically always me
being like
something has got to give because this
is not sustainable in the first six
months of our marriage we separated
now you noticed something he has not
changed
damn first six months at all
he's the same guy she was dating the
same guy she chased after
the same guy she married the same guy
she's now married to
he hasn't changed she wanted him to
change
she expected him to change but he didn't
change
he's still the a-hole she got involved
with except now they're married
and again this is for him asking her to
marry him and him not just saying you
know what
i can't do this i'm not in a healthy
place to do this myself
because he did that well this is what
she's going through
but she had plenty of opportunity
like going way back to when they first
started dating and he wouldn't commit to
her
that's when she should have called it
quit yeah but she can't
she can't the fifi's the butterfly is
too strong
and that's so it's hard and the older
you get the more you realize like how
dumb you were when you were young and
i'm not even that old
i'm 24 but like
and it takes like this is why i say be
very careful
who you date and who you interact with
because
you never know like
you never know who
is going to like damage you in a way
that's going to take years to repair
i was already gonna this is when i made
that video and i said marriage is hard
and i pretty much like
never thought we were gonna get back
together we were legally separated
hadn't spoken in months like literally
he was living in arizona i was living in
california
didn't think we would ever get back
together met a guy at coachella
we definitely hooked up it's a whole
thing my whole family knows he made sure
to tell everyone in my family it's great
um i'm not proud of that okay well
here's the thing
first they were separated for several
months second
they were legally separated which in
many places you have to do one year
before your divorce
happens so it's part of the divorce
process
does that give her a pass no it does not
why because look at the the crap
she's dragging around with her look how
unhappy she is
look at she's she hasn't resolved one
relationship
yet and she's moving from relationship
to relationship
to relationship now the coachella may
have just been a hookup thing
look if if that's your deal that is what
it is but
what are you getting out of it you're
you're so twisted and having such a hard
time with life
that can only add more to it
surprisingly
it does and that's
that's what women like that's what you
don't realize
is the repercussions of things that may
seem
small um and again like i said
i take radical responsibility in a lot
of this it takes two a lot of the time
but i will say you guys
as god as my witness
over the last year and a half i'd say a
year at least
i have been doing so much
self-development work i enrolled myself
in like high-level
emotional intelligence training and i've
been
all right so she's she's at least now at
32
trying to better herself trying to learn
from her mistakes and again
she talks another 30 minutes about what
she's learned the mistakes she's made
so this is not her bragging by any means
i you know i want to make that clear
but it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
because
she's leaving a trail of destruction
in her wake as is the guy that she dated
just leaving a trail of destruction in
her wake in his wake
and so you've got two bulldozers just
going through life
wrecking people as they go because they
haven't stopped
to fix things as they were going now
maybe she has
but how many people did she hurt along
the way now i've done it too
i've done it too i'm not saying i'm any
different but i'm bringing this forward
as an opposing voice to my voice so you
can maybe see
some of the things i'm saying here the
opposite side of the
the the view right straight from the
horse's mouth so to speak
did you know that when you're in love
your brain literally looks like it's on
drugs
and that's why people act so insane and
like
act beyond logic when they're in love
um but most days i didn't want to get
out of bed i was not eating right
i was i mean it got dark it got
really dark and i just felt so
trapped so obviously things are winding
down in the marriage
and again all her choices seem to not be
working out
all because and a lot of this i think
stems from a bad
family maybe some bad early on
relationships
maybe something that was kind of abusive
and bad happened early on
but when that happens you're not a
healthy
individual and you don't know how to do
things in a healthy way
and so you get into unhealthy
relationships
and including ones that are unhealthy to
you
and unhealthy that you do to other
people and i think that's what's
happening to her
what have you guys found is the best way
to heal from like
previous trauma do you found it's like
meditation therapy
let me know in the comments now she's
had a little time of clarity
um maybe she's learned from that but she
certainly uh took herself down into a
very dark place
so not only she reckon everybody lives
that she's touched
me as far as relationships but she's
wrecking her
own she's not in a good place and she's
certainly not happy but everything she's
done isn't making it any better that's
the takeaway here
is that you know this may be the girl
that you meet
in any stage of your life and you don't
know all this that's going on behind the
scenes
and all of a sudden it messes you up so
here's an opportunity to understand that
maybe things happened
that you don't know what happened but as
a guy you can give yourself some
forgiveness
and and not be hating on yourself or
thinking you did something wrong
when the bulldozer was on its own course
and you just got in the way and you
didn't even know it
i don't know where we're gonna go from
here and then it started to be
physically abusive on his end to me and
i wouldn't have
dared reciprocate otherwise i would be
dead
there was a couple times that were such
close calls
i don't even yeah i don't i don't know i
want to be really
careful i'm like i didn't really even
plan on showing this much now i'm not
going to give the guy a pass
you know now some of you guys say hey if
if she hits you you hit you
hit her back or she hits you defend
yourself i'll give you a defend
now you you guys some of you would have
a different logic than this for me
um i know one of the reasons why i'm
very chill
most of the time is because when i lose
my temper i go into a
red blind rage so i've learned
to not lose my temper most like
through the majority of my life because
if i were to
reciprocate it would not be good so i
don't
some of you feel differently you
shouldn't ever hurt a woman if you're in
a relationship where she's hitting you
and like abusing you
it's on you to walk away you know what
like
there's obviously like situations where
you have to defend yourself
but i'm just having a hard time
seeing like when if i'm stronger
because i have siblings right and my
siblings that i'm stronger than even if
they like
hit me like at a point where one of my
sisters
like punched me but she was younger but
instead of like punching her back
i literally just like held her down so
she couldn't like do it anymore
and then like didn't talk to her for a
while obviously it's my sister i can't
like
you know undo that or like not see her
again but
you guys get what i'm saying like if the
case of a woman can't you just hold her
down
until she like calms down and like walk
away
but let me know in the comments i've
never obviously been in a situation
where i've dealt with crazy woman so
about that i personally i just don't
it's just not in my wheelhouse i would
rather give get out of the situation
but whether she started it he defended
whether he started it she defended
either way that's not the debate here
the debate is both
people are extremely poisonous
but whether she got poisoned by him or
she was poisoned already
the whole point is neither one of them
are in a good place
but she went out and dated other people
and dragged other people into this
that's why i found this so fascinating
and this is why i tell women
literally if there's a guy that you
can't control your attraction to
take yourself out of the situation
i don't care and this is gonna set this
might sound dramatic
it i don't care if you have to switch
jobs
or move or do whatever like
you need that space and you will waste
years
with the wrong person like imagine if
okay she was in that situation right
where she
spent like five years at like in that
whatever talking
hooking up stage with that guy what if
she a year and she said i'm way too
attached to this guy
i need to move out of the state so i'm
not tempted to hang out with him and
talk to him anymore
so at least i i can't see him like in
person
right imagine how much
better of a place she would be in if you
don't have the willpower
to like stay away don't make it an
option
is if if this were a story of he was a
bad guy i dated him
we got married and i bro you know bad
things happen and we broke up and
divorced at the end
there's not a story here i mean it's a
maybe
if about the narcissism and the
gaslighting maybe there's a story there
the story is here on this video is the
wake of destruction of all the other
relationships that maybe he left
and maybe she left we don't know what he
did but she even admits
the wake of destruction she left all
these other innocent guys
here i am like trying to talk about
positivity and all of this and trying to
create like a difference in the world
and we're literally
like killing each other inside you know
like this is so dark i was like can't we
just like
get a divorce and like move on like we
can't keep doing this corey this is
so dark and then he would like guide us
into meditation the next day because he
would wake up on a good side so i'm like
it was
very like i literally felt like i was on
a roller coaster
that's what narcissists do um
because i i've read up i'm not an expert
i'm not a psychologist or a psychiatrist
but
i know about this because i've dated a
couple of them and and it's kind of
crazy
because do you think people throw around
that word too
often because i really don't believe
people a lot of the time
when they say that like they say
they dated narcissist like i found
they've just dated someone who's an
[ __ ]
because you think things are that's it
that's it i'm out it's over it's this is
too
much nuts for me and then the next day
everything's fine
i was just having a bad day let's move
on and they're back to being the person
that you care for very much
so you say all right well let's hang in
there for another few days or a week or
a month
and then it happens again and that's it
and it keeps it keeps pulling you in
the difference is when you're confident
you're in a good place in your life and
you're healthy
you can leave and it or at least it's
easier to leave
because narcissists are just a weird
trap but if you're in a bad place or
you're not happy or you're depressed or
whatever
you feel like you're leaving your world
behind to leave these people
especially if you give up a lot of
things for a relationship
and it sounds like what's happened to
her she just got stuck sucked in
and didn't know how to leave the
maelstrom so part of me does feel
sorry that she's in the situation
but again she got here by her own
choices
oh and let me add she takes
accountability for that i've
cut a lot of this out i'm not being
harsh on her that she takes
accountability for her choices
but again this is looking backwards it's
easier to do when you're looking
backwards
but if you were the guy that tried to
date her in the middle of this
you might think it was your fault or
your problem or your issue and then you
walk out of that situation
i was just telling one of my guy friends
just the other day like
guys even even if you have no options
do not go for the girl that's in
a whatever like talking whatever
stage with another guy don't do that to
yourself i know you might not have a lot
of like options to choose from
because i think that's kind of how he
felt like he really liked her
but you don't you don't want to be
someone's second choice situation
thinking that you've got the problem
when it's actually her that's got the
problem yeah
um i knew i needed to start building my
exit strategy
to get out because i started seeing it
go down a really weird turn
but inside i was like i just was wishing
for this like
miracle to happen where he would just
like snap
out of it and like something would give
and um
and and they always say they try to
change
the man and i think what actually
happens is women just focus on like the
positive qualities like
when he was really kind or he was really
sweet to her thinking that
like that's the real him and not you
know
all the other red flags
that was like obviously delusional even
at the end after everything
she still wishes things could change
just too much of a draw
and now especially after going to peru
and doing all of this healing work and
like
really committing myself to like daily
daily getting
my mind and my heart right um
i couldn't be any clearer that this is
the right decision
i think it's a good thing i i think it
obviously that
they got divorced she got out of it it's
a good thing now she has about half a
million subs
um her whole video is very helpful
i'm i i didn't want to make this video
just to trash on her because i cut out
just about everything nice she said and
all the apologies that she said and all
the advice she has
and she's got good advice and it's not
white knighting it's not being a simp
it's just simply
acknowledging she understands now
what happened yeah be that as it may
the the people that she hurt along the
way and that wasn't even necessarily
intentional
but it's to show what a very strong
charismatic
maybe attractive that high
value guy how much pull
that can have on a woman's emotions
it'll make her do
crazy things and this is for the people
that say that women are only in it for
the money
no money he offered irrational things
make bad decisions
hurt other people even against her own
will
because that's and and men do the same
thing when look at some of these guys
that we talk about that are
you know sending women checks for
thousands of dollars
they've never met they're an only fans
whatever and they're hoping these
thousands of dollars
will win them the affection of this
woman and
and then the woman posts on a post or on
a you know a
twitter or whatever like look at these
idiots that are sending me thousands of
dot men do it too
men do it too okay i think i'm gonna end
it on that note
this guy's so wise like this is gonna be
i'm definitely gonna binge watch him
he's my new favorite like nano sphere
channel i think he offers a lot of like
really practical advice
but this is i know there's a lot of men
it's interesting because i made this
channel like for women but men
like men watch it is an interesting
thing i think a lot of girls
sorry i'm stretching don't realize like
all the stuff that's like at play
behind the scenes and i think a lot of
girls like
realize that a guy is like not
good for them but they think that he
would be like so much better for someone
else and it's something to do with them
and a lot of times it's just their
character
but let me know in the comments because
i think of
i've kind of rambled a lot this video
let me know in the comments
what you agree with or disagree with let
me know what i should react to next time
and thank you
for watching as always